deuxième journée de tournage pour nous à
hong kong
alors cette journée elle a commencé pour
moi car du visionnement c'est à dire
qu'il faut regarder les entrevues le
visuel qu'on a tourné hier pour choisir
les meilleurs extraits ont vite commencé
la structure du reportage la
réalisatrice aussi faisait ça de
chantier t on s'est partagé la tâche et
pendant ce temps notre cameraman lui
prenait des images de la ville des gens
dans la rue bref ce qui va me servir
après pour le montage
ensuite on est allé rencontrer de jeunes
militants des militants qu'on dit plus
radicaux c'est à dire qu'ils n'hésitent
pas à se confronter avec la police il
est ainsi intéressant parce qu'ils ont à
peu près 23 24 ans sont assez articulés
sont assez idéaliste et ils ont montré
aujourd'hui leur attirail ce qu'ils
utilisent pendant les manifestations des
masques à gaz des lance-pierres des
lampes de poche aussi pour pouvoir
essayer de déjouer les policiers eux
disent qu'ils ne se serve de tout ça que
pour leur protection
pour se protéger des forces policières
puis on est allé rejoindre un autre
manifestant seins ni 23 ans lui aussi
très articulé qui lui aussi a défendu la
cause des protestataires
alors c'est quand même impressionnant de
voir ces jeunes qui sont très très
politisée puis vint ça a été une partie
un peu plus fastidieuse peut-être deux
du métier c'est à dire que j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps au téléphone essayer
de rejoindre des gens d'affaires parce
que il ya beaucoup de gens à hong kong
qui sont très très qui ceux qui
soutiennent bien sûr la cause des
manifestants mais aussi beaucoup de gens
d'affaires commencent à s'inquiéter des
répercussions de tout ça sur l'économie
de hong kong qui trouve aussi que les
médias sont beaucoup trop sympathique à
la cause des contestataires mais qui
sont hésitants à parler à la caméra
parce qu'il craint que cela puisse leur
nuire nuire à leur affaire aussi donc on
verra un peu plus tard si j'ai été assez
convaincante ensuite au bain il a fallu
tourner quelques présentations à la
caméra et là bas il est 7h30 on a on
s'est arrêté pour prendre une bouchée
mais on n'a pas fini encore notre
journée puisque ensuite il faut
continuer à visionner traduire les
entrevues pour la fête en pantalon alors
je crois qu'il est temps d'y aller on va
se parler de marque